[Musique]
bonjour et bien c'est sympathique de
savoir que vous êtes toujours fidèle au
rendez-vous de la cuisine légère
michel guérard n'est pas encore arrivé
mais vous savez une va sûrement pas
tarder vous s'il vous est très fidèle
alors je sais qu'aujourd'hui il a
l'intention de vous donner la recette du
poisson rôti au four et des nouilles au
citron alors bas mon dieu j'ai devant
moi
les ingrédients je vais peut-être
pouvoir commencer bonjour ma petite elle
marie bonjour à mon nom n'apparaissait
pas non et bien voilà je suis la cantine
de michel kaham et ma boucle vous
parlais de ce que vous avez fait michel
c'est mon neveu il choisit pas sa
viabilité
un sacré gain alors écoutez je voudrais
je vais vous dire quelque chose que
personne ne sait les passions et que les
éditions télévision oui c'est moi qui
m'y prépare alors comme il n'est pas
plus cette semaine je me suis dit vas
pas dire et alors comme il est pas beau
du bois je suis venu et pas mais ces
sentiments bien la télévision bon alors
j'espère que ça va pas du tout alors je
vais faire comme j'ai l'habitude de
montrer michel oui j'aime les femmes
vous n'avez que je lui explique tout
alors bien sûr j'ai moins de mémoire
j'ai pris un pense bête et puis mes
lunettes
parce que c'est bien bon alors on m'a
dit nous avons commencer par le
commencement n'est ce pas alors
aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de faire un rôti
de poisson oui alors un petit poisson
réplique du collage et but de colin prix
que c'est pas un poisson chic chic
d'ailleurs qui voudrait dire que les
poissons cherchent et qui deviennent de
plus en plus cher
là ça devient même impossible bon donc
nous avons un kilo 4 de colin et ce
pacte alors avec quelques gousses d'ail
qui vont cuire au four la banque
1 voilà et alors là un petit peu de
l'huile d'olive musique n'a rien eh bien
il ya subi hier à vent à cordes ou alors
via ses cuillères ses cuillères d'huile
d'olive qui vous permette au rôti de
poissons de tyr liban
alors je vais bien je vais mais
l'allemand du sel et du poivre
après la petite après bonnet vous que
jamais maître du 10 et du poil mais a
ici vous avez des feuilles de lauriers
alors je vais 1 6 et 1 6 et le peso
n'est ce pas comme ça alors voyez comme
ça et j'ai mis ces pauvres c'est pas bon
de penser que vous êtes le visio 1
mais c'est alors et michel à boé où ça
m'étonne pas de lui vous savez après il
viendra se plaindre mais enfin c'est
toujours pareil hein
mais bon à l'aller bonjour 10 ou les
mauvais niveau liche et plus ou moins
bien ils ont toujours mauvais outil
alors jean 6
donc ça sera pour m pour mettre leur
levier
bon alors comme ça sera en particulier
pap
je mettrai quelques morceaux de tomates
au four pour ce tour tout le monde
pressent un pelé ou pas ils n'ont pas
plu non non non non écouter sur la
cuisine de femme aujourd'hui je ne
dirais pas de sottises pas parce que
nous sommes devant alors ça c'est du
bouillon que j'ajouterai à la fin pour
faire ma sauce d'accord y'a de la crème
et l'or j'ajouterai à leur sale dans la
crème c'est tout à fait pour autant de
choses à vous voyez pas me parler
non je vais vous en parler la crème ça
sera là pour faire les nouilles au
citron anciens vos lunettes un oui oh
oui oh la la
alors oui ça fait la quatrième perte que
jusqu'à cette semaine alors c'est elle
oui et dit voir alors le beurre n'est ce
pas que vous voyez là pas avec la crème
eux ce sera pour faire des nouilles
aussi trop avant parce que la nouille à
la nouille s'ils comprennent les
merveilleux bon alors vous savez bon
alors là de marie on va commencer par le
commencement n'est ce pas ce que je vous
ai dit tout à l'heure alors dans ma
plaque à rôtir
j'ai mis ces cuillères d'huile et puis
alors mon échalotes
alors comme ça tu les changes et les
mois très durs pour moi que j'ai mis des
mitaines ce genre de travail avec des
gants c'est gênant
alors je vais mettre dedans que le
secteur est en beta c'est là mon âge
vous savez je mets mes feuilles de
l'oise et la spa comme ceci ou le garder
marie peu plus tôt comme ça voilà je les
enfonce un tout petit peu dedans c'est
un joli pour la décoration travail et
qu'il avait cette idée michel non je ne
crois pas toutes façons de vous dire
quelque chose il n'a pas du tout l'idée
c'est toutes les recettes qui fait c'est
moi alors bon je suis fier de moi vous
savez mes gars longtemps qu'il y avait
il ya longtemps que je cuisine qu il ya
très longtemps
ouf ma pauvre petit vous savez on va pas
je pas donné mon âge ici ma femme non
mais enfin mais c'est pas votre métier
je vais dire que rafa n'est pas mon
métier
absolument pas maître maryvonne chiffres
avec c'est exactement c'est comme ça que
j'ai pu obtenir mon mari à la maison une
très mauvaise époque je reconnais que ça
a failli mal se terminer
et alors j'ai plein d'autres comiques
comme ça et j'ai vaincu bien alors
barillet balle juste à l'espoir comme
ceux ci n'ont pas là assez abondamment
là comme ce pas brillé vous est alors je
le donne des poules de moulin à poivre
comme ça là avec une certaine assurance
le poivre se libère mieux du moulin à
poivre comme ceci voilà alors oui oui
enfin bon j'ai eu des problèmes avec mon
mari mais le sait bien
marie très dur
alors oui ça aussi comme ça je sais
comme ça chez coyote
alors elle marie n'est ce pas avec un
petit peu d'huile qui vous veut s'il
vous plaît alors j'arrose comme ceci
voilà oui et alors là maintenant je vais
rentrer le tour alors je vais donc faire
le rôti de boisson alors le lieu pour
est à combien
alors il est gelé mis au thermostat 8 8
faire bien attention un prénom 250 alors
que l'on tourne pas comme ça et puis
lors là on peut même servir ou mais ma
foi va à peu près 25 minutes 25 minutes
alors pendant ce temps là alors prince
temps là on va faire autre chose mais
quand même en cours de route et spa je
vais ouvrir le four une fois je vais
couper les tomates en hiver
et puis jarre oserait encore d'accord
alors les tomates
je veux bien qu'on les prépare
maintenant y'a pas de raison n'est ce
pas voilà la 40 minute quand j'arrive à
travailler sans lunettes
aujourd'hui même et vous rendez vous
qu'est ce que vous êtes bien la
télévision et aux biens ou mais bouffé
ohlala vous savez c'est pas que je
serais très très très beau ou la la la
la draf à lui dire oui au bon faut bien
les femmes on sent quand même que je
crois que j'emploie chocolat je
comprends pas d'ailleurs qu'ils prennent
toujours des hommes parce que c'est
quand même un petit peu tannant mais pas
les speakerines c'est pas des hommes
c'est cette raison à mes champs vol
quand même discipline qui sont hommes ce
qui donne les informations la laverie
journalistes sa tasse et des
journalistes a bien dont des
journalistes tient alors vous voyez ce
qu'il faut des spas travailler avec
délicatesse bat toujours avec
délicatesse se place d'un point de tout
quoi un bon voilà alors là tout ça c
coupé alors je vais vous montrer pendant
ce par là
comme on prépare les nouilles aussi
trois oui alors ça quelle drôle d'idée
alors ça c'est une recette que j'ai
ramené d'italie
j'étais champion d'italie avec une
troisième a dit très bien entraîné la
très chic plein d'argent et ils les
parties m'abandonner celui-là et enfin
qu'est ce que vous voulez dans le fond
d'une casserole
on met une petite noix de beurre comme
ceci n'est ce pas voilà bien à peine
alors dans cette casserole n'est ce pas
j'ajoute du gaz est de 6,3 oui c'est
alors ici sont déjà de grandes baies et
alors c est de six tombes en cuir dans
le beurre alors je vais enlever ce plat
là parce qu'il sert à rien ça chez moi
j'ai plus l'habitude c'est pendant le
camp comment ça marche ça je sais pas du
tout moi je touche ma profession n'a pas
d'importance
n'est ce pas alors ligne ou n'est ce pas
le les zestes de citron vampires dans le
parfumer le beurre aussi trop alors une
fois que ce sera parfumé et puis alors
la cena le petit secret je vais ajouter
un petit peu de vin blanc
voilà comme je l'avais marges en italie
on a ajouté du champagne mais c'est dans
un palace alors s'il faut quand même
faire attention tu ailles de champagne
dans notre gestion c'est pas la peine
alors donc comme colas je pense que ça
va non non mon zeste de citron râpé et
bien accueilli à ce moment là j'ajoute
le vin blanc d'accord alors
j'ajoute au voilà voilà quatrièmes
quelqu'un
voilà alors le vin blanc je vais laisser
bouillir bouillet billet vous dire fin
et alors quand il est presque yves
apparaît alors là ce moment-là rajout de
la crème à l'orge à chaudun cuillère
comme ça de crem
et puis deux grosses cuillères également
deux heures je savais je sois la fille
alors vous voyez rendu avec marie voyer
laisse pas le
le citron le geste qu est qu il est un
peu de quatre classes à la télévision
c'est parfait biya de beurre et de
cuillères de crème
n'est ce pas le cheveu ajouter la crème
comme ceci d'un seul coup oui à tout
l'espace comme ceux ci la voilà et alors
je vais laisser réduire d'un tout petit
peu oui déçu pour sa part moi j'aime
bien quand c'est l'accident le béa
j'aime bien j'aime bien on a des doutes
ligne bien qu'une femme c'est pareil à
vous et moi aussi mon petit poisson qui
cuisent liban alors je prends une partie
du jus et la charraud de jarod j'arrose
veille anne-marie j'arrose bien comme ça
hein on en est plus prégnante passe
encore
biya pas il n'y a pas encore les dix
minutes ont permis voit pas on va
attendre un petit moment
alors voyez ma crème à bouilly n'est ce
pas alors maintenant bain j'ajoute le
beurre et alors tout ça ça va faire une
espèce de unissent plus de crèches pour
être pour vous dire quoi comment
exactement une espèce de crème contour y
comme ça et puis alors là ça va nous
permettre tout à l'heure de cuire les
nouilles de de condiments t comme on dit
des quizz vous voyez le mari de sparte
ont pu jours cuire les nouilles d'avancé
alors on l'aimé réchauffer dans l'eau
chaude ou non elles resteraient très
bien maintenant ça fait douze minutes
n'est ce pas que leur petit poisson cuit
alors voulez-vous ma portée je veux pas
me salir les mains
voulez vous apportez l'ailé droite la
voile la craie bien très bien
alors les pam appui moral et je me suis
remis maintenant piment toujours l'homme
de ça alors les tomates je l'aimé comme
ça pour du plein voilà comme ceci
et puis alors on va laisser cuire n'est
ce pas douze minutes encore
voilà c'est tout
la bourse de paris anne-marie alors à
côté mais alors sa petite marie bien sûr
on peut parler comme ça où je parle je
parle je parle mais alors motivé truc
mais il tient à l'énerver
je suis avec vous je les vois plus le
temps passe et aux basses et sa taille a
alors servi le régime n'est ce pas je
vais le débat c est sur mon plat
alors qu'en principe c'est que vous en
avez eu des malheurs finalement aux mets
ma pauvre mari vous pouvez pas savoir le
plat rappelle qu'il est jeune on le met
à chauffer ça je le mets ou chauffour
est-ce que ça c'est clair
oui à mon avis oui je vais à c'était
joli l'once et à l'union hainaut les
défunts et puis ça doit être bon ou très
bon très très bon alors je vais mouiller
pas le fond du plat et leur jeu la joute
mon nom mon demi litre de bouillon de
volaille alors comme ceci voilà su si
vous n'avez pas de bouillon vous c'est
quand même meilleur c'est bien alors
n'est ce pas ça bout pour garder tout
allait bien clal projecteurs de la
télévision se battre sur moi 1 comme
ceci alors je vais lancer d'un seul coup
ceci voilà c'est bien la faute de
l'énergie terrestre vise in de l'énergie
alors je regrette je gratouille comme
ceci avec ma cuillère n'est ce pas avec
le fond du plat en vie et alors je veux
le mettre à bouillir
alors dès que ça bouge je vais passer ça
dans ma passoire ça je vais appuyer
comme ça pour que tous leila la commande
tout ça ça passe au travers de la
passoire
ça va venir c'est grâce aux alors à
bouillir bourboule bouillir et puis
alors tout à l'heure je joue très le
restons donc et elle inquiète pas bien
non même s'il est là il est là mais pas
mis de côté
les favoris alors il faut pas me faire
des choses comme ça bien alors
maintenant je vais mettre dans ma
casseroles ce site
alors ce que je vous demanderais maps et
anne-marie c'est de me tenir un rat mais
ça serait très bien le faire serait bien
trash député aïda net
attention à vos lunettes avaient tenté
avant comme si vous vouliez pas tantinet
la fois là comme ceci très bien aux
bouchers l'habitude vous savez où vous
vous et comme c'est qu'il a commencé
michel avec vous alors en vous tenant
l'est oui vous savez il continue à tenir
le manche de la castre boots à peu près
tout ce qu'il sait faire et je lui ai
dit tout à l'heure c'est pas la peine de
revenir là-dessus bon de vous comprenez
m'obliger à mon âge me demande de venir
le remplacer à la télévision il fait au
cinéma stable à vous comme n'est allé
voir un film pendant la fiq une chose
comme ça l'est on est capable mais il en
est capable vous avez aussi des jeux
vous imaginez pas comme ça des tours et
un livre dont tiens je vais pas laisser
bien jeune et encore avec les âmes non
là n'est ce pas je vais faire réduire et
je vais même aller du milliard à
riquewihr la fox a beau faut que ça
bouge et puis alors comme ça va être
réduite à peu près un quart mais je vais
ajouter mon beurre et soit et comme ça
avec le point et puis la sauce rapide et
bon voilà bon leurs vendeurs de tout à
l'heure cela je vais le saluer pour
redonner le moulin à poivre
comme ceci voilà très bien comme ça
voyez partout qui peut bien alors un
petit pull dublin pas vrai
alors là je lui dis toujours à mon neveu
mais mais mais en trois mois du poivre
blanc parce que le garder ça fait tout
noir n'est ce pas
c'est faux tout leur rappelons enfin
c'est comme ça bon alors je me je
rajoute monju titre auront comme ceci
voilà eux mais nous elles sont chaudes
alors je vais je vais l'irlande rcba
seul coup dans la casserole d'assassins
toute façon s'il reste un peu d'humilité
ça n'a pas d'importance
désolé voilà alors ça vous savez cette
famille souvent il n'a pas de mérite
c'est parce que sûrement même du lycée
car quand je pense qu'il est filmé
photographié alors ça vous savez ce
procès alors tout autour un marinesque à
skhirat ont dominé je vais affronter
n'ont jamais vu je voudrais bien écouté
ma vie alors ça écoute et je pourrais
lui dire je lui glisserait la prochaine
fois quand tu vas au cinéma comme ça
raconte anne-marie pour attaquer le
téléski yang
non c'est pas comme si curieuse alors
permettez à volonté et alors si vous le
permettez je vous inviterai à monsec et
marc je suis découvert c'était notre
poisson d'avril
j'étais bien dans ce rôle de tante inera
très bien bravo est un très très bon
plat qui sera sûrement des listings si
elle n'a rien de facile à pessan la
paire et que c'est pas ça peut-être
[Rires]
[Musique]